-You have not always been
a writer
and an actor and a comedian.
You did some work at the mall
over the years.
-I did. I went to the mall
the other day, locally,
where I live,
and it was a really dead mall.
There were only
like three things in it now,
and just a lot of posters that
were sort of positive messages.
They had shuttered-up stores.
And they were like giant
greeting cards,
but I spent so much of
my high school years in the mall
in Orlando area,
and I worked at York Steakhouse.
And York Steakhouse, you know,
I loved restaurant work
because I hated being bored
and I loved anything
that was just like a hustle
and I was just sweating,
and I guess that's why I loved
"SNL" so much.
But I just loved,
like, having a lot to do.
And I had this manager
that just, you know,
he always supported
my performing career
and everything,
and he came to me.
He was always trying to, like,
throw me a bone on anything that
was performative of any kind,
and so he -- I was, you know,
serving the food and being
the cashier, and he came one day
and he was like,
"We're doing a promotion
with Strawberry Shortcake,
the character.
And what if you played
Strawberry Shortcake
in a costume outside
the restaurant, inside the mall
and give helium balloons to
the kids and try to get people
in for the special
that we are having?"
And so I did it
for like three weeks,
and it was really exciting. Yes,
I was exactly in that costume.
-Here's Strawberry Shortcake
for those who don't remember.
-I had like four freckles
on each cheek,
and I had a little --
a bunch of blush,
and I had this giant red wig,
and it was very clown-like
but like a fem clown.
And I -- Every week --
this is how old I am --
there used to be a Wurlitzer
organ store in the mall.
And so every week, on Sundays,
they would take,
in the freight elevator,
they would send the organ up --
that's what she said...
[ Laughter ]
...and they'd send the organ up
the freight elevator.
And then they would have these
old men -- old men and old women
there and they'd have desserts
free and coffee, and then
the guy would play the organ
for a couple hours at night,
and then they would all die.
No, I'm just kidding.
[ Laughter ]
They wouldn't die.
And so I --
One night he comes out,
and I'm still
Strawberry Shortcake.
And he goes, "Come here."
He goes, "I just -- I just love
the way you sing.
What if you sang something
for all these people?"
And I said, "Well, I didn't
rehearse any of this."
I don't even know if he's got
anything that I know.
And I was real nervous,
and he pulled me in there,
and he had the piano book, and
the only song of about 500 songs
I knew in the piano book,
in the organ book, which I sang,
including like four verses of,
was this.
Picture my Strawberry Shortcake.
♪ Were you there
when they crucified my Lord? ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ Were you there
when they crucified ♪
And it was just a pan across,
as if it was an "SNL" sketch,
of just a lot of people
being very sad about
this maudlin song with a scary,
little, young, chubby clown
in front of them singing it.
[ Laughter ]
It's the stuff of nightmares.
And then I worked in a gift shop
in the mall,
and I used to order Chick-fil-A
chicken and biscuits
in the morning.
I'd volunteer
to go get breakfast.
I'd run down there,
I'd get chicken and biscuits.
I'd get one extra for me,
and then I would eat it
under the escalator
behind the plants,
and then I would come up with,
like, biscuit spackle
across my teeth and pretend
I was really hungry
like, "Let's have breakfast!"
[ Laughter ]
I had a lot of fun in the mall.
-I do like talking to you
about your animals.
You are an animal lover,
a renowned animal lover.
How many pets do you have now?
-I have two horses.
I just acquired an old horse
that I used to have,
and I got a rescue horse
to be her companion.
I have four dogs,
and I have a 21-year-old cat.
-Which dog is this?
-That's Ernie.
-Okay.
-And that picture is enjoyable
because it looks like I drooled
all the way down my shirt.
Or he peed on me,
which he did not do.
But Ernie has --
Ernie has an overbite.
He has four -- He's my new dog
I got from California
before I moved to New York
again.
He has a four-teeth overbite.
It's a real journey.
-We've got a nice reveal.
So, here's the first one,
and everybody can picture
what a four-toothed overbite
looks like.
And there you go.
[ Laughter ]
-Yep. That's Ernie.
And he's got a really weird
personality,
and we finally figured him out.
At first we thought he was just
a little bit of a Chihuahua
being a jerk and -- because he
started getting real aggressive
with the other dogs, and then we
realized he's just like a human
that's super awkward and doesn't
have a lot of skills or game,
so he'll just be like...
[ Barks ]
...when he wants to play,
and so you're always
scolding him,
thinking he's attacking things,
and then he really
just wants to play,
so I'm really trying to
get to know him
and understand
that he's a weirdo.
-Not a great first-impression
dog.
It seems like you want to spend
some time with him.
-Yeah.
Yeah, we don't want to have --
We have a lot of animals, so if
one starts fighting the other,
it's pretty much --
it's like a Greek arena.
You just watch
everyone kill each other.
-Congratulations on everything.
Best of luck this weekend
on your Emmy nomination,
and it's always just such
a delight to see you, Paula.
-Thank you. I love you,
and I wish I could be there.
I'll be there next time.
-Alright, we love you too.
"A.P. Bio" is streaming now
on Peacock.